Esto es, de hecho, un número increíblemente grande,
porque realmente necesitamos recoger algo con suficiente antelación
y hacer algo significativo al respecto,
debemos recoger tumores que tienen mil células
y lo ideal es solo un puñado de células.
Así que estamos bastante lejos de esto.
Juguemos a un pequeño experimento aquí.
Les pediré a cada uno de Uds. que imaginen
que son neurocirujanos.
Y Uds. están ahora en una sala de operaciones,
y hay un paciente ante Ud.
y su tarea es asegurarse de que el tumor se haya extinguido.
Así que Ud. mira hacia el paciente,
la piel y el cráneo ya se han apartado,
ahora Ud. busca en el cerebro.
Y todo lo que sabe de este paciente
es que hay un tumor del tamaño de una pelota de golf o menos
en el lóbulo frontal derecho del cerebro de esta persona.
Y eso es más o menos todo.
Así que Ud. está mirando y por desgracia, todo parece igual,
porque el tejido del cáncer del cerebro y el tejido cerebral sano
en realidad tienen el mismo aspecto.
Así que pasa por encima con el pulgar,
y se empieza a presionar un poco en el cerebro,
porque los tumores tienden a ser algo más fuertes, más rígidos,
y así uno se adentra un poco y dice:
"Parece que el tumor está ahí".
Luego, uno toma e bisturí y empieza a cortar el tumor
trozo a trozo.
Y mientras recorta el tumor,
uno llega al momento que piensa:
"Muy bien, he terminado. Saqué todo".
Y en ese momento,
—hasta ahora todo parecía bastante loco—
uno está a punto de enfrentarse a la decisión más difícil de su vida.
Porque ahora hay que decidir,
parar ahí y dejar estar a este paciente,
arriesgando haber dejado células cancerosas sobrantes
que no se podían ver,
o llegar a márgenes adicionales,
típicamente cerca de una pulgada o menos alrededor del tumor
solo para asegurarse de que quita todo.
Así que esto no es una decisión fácil de tomar
y, por desgracia, esta es la decisión
que los neurocirujanos de cáncer tienen que tomar a diario
cuando ven a sus pacientes.
Y así recuerdo haber hablado con amigos míos en el laboratorio:
"Debe existir una mejor manera".
Pero no de la forma que se dice a un amigo que debe haber una mejor manera.
Tiene que existir una manera mejor para esto.
Esto es simplemente increíble.
Y así que miramos hacia atrás.
Recuerden esos escaneos PET de los que hablé, el azúcar, etc.
Dijimos, ¿qué hay en lugar de moléculas de azúcar?
Tomemos diminutas partículas, hechas de oro,
y programémoslas con la química interesante que les rodea.
Programémoslas para buscar células cancerosas.
Y luego inyectemos estas partículas de oro
de a miles de millones en estos pacientes
e irán por todo el cuerpo,
y al igual que agentes secretos,
caminando por todas las células del cuerpo
llamando a la puerta de cada célula
preguntado: "¿Eres una célula cancerosa o sana?
Si eres una célula sana, seguimos camino.
Si eres una célula cancerosa, nos pegaremos a ti para resplandecer.
informándonos: "Mira, estoy aquí".
Y lo harán a través de cámaras
que hemos desarrollado en el laboratorio.
Y una vez que lo veamos, podamos, tal vez, guiar a los neurocirujanos de cáncer
hacia la extracción solo del tumor dejando el cerebro sano en paz.
Y por lo que hemos probado, esto funciona bien.
Así que mostraré un ejemplo ahora.
Lo que estamos viendo aquí
es una imagen del cerebro de un ratón,
y hemos implantado en el cerebro de este ratón
un pequeño tumor.
Y este tumor crece en el cerebro de este ratón,
y luego pedimos a un cirujano
operar el ratón como si fuera un paciente,
y sacar trozo a trozo el tumor.
Y mientras que él lo está haciendo,
tomamos las imágenes para ver dónde están las partículas de oro.
Y así vamos hacia la primera incisión
con la inyección de las partículas de oro en este ratón,
y veamos aquí, en la izquierdo hay
esa imagen en la parte inferior
es la imagen que muestra donde están las partículas de oro.
Lo bueno es que estas partículas de oro
han hecho todo el camino hasta el tumor,
y luego brillan y nos dicen: "Estamos aquí. Aquí está el tumor".
Así que ahora podemos ver el tumor,
pero todavía no se lo mostramos al médico.
Pedimos al médico que ahora empiece a extirpar el tumor,
y ven aquí que el médico acaba de extirpar el primer cuadrante del tumor
y ven que el primer cuadrante ahora falta.
Luego, el médico extirpa el segundo cuadrante, el tercero,
y ahora parece ya está todo.
Y así, en esta etapa, el médico se volvió a nosotros y dijo:
"Muy bien, he terminado. ¿Qué más quieren que haga?
¿Debo dejar las cosas como están
o quieren que tome unos márgenes adicionales?"
Y entonces dijimos: "Espera".
Le dijimos al médico: "No has extirpado esos dos puntos,
así que en lugar de extirpar grandes márgenes de alrededor,
extirpa solo esas pequeñas áreas.
Hazlo y luego echaremos un vistazo".
Así el médico lo extirpó, y he aquí,
el cáncer ahora ha desaparecido por completo.
Ahora, lo importante,
no es que el cáncer ha desaparecido por completo
del cerebro de esta persona,
o del cerebro de este ratón.
Lo más importante
es que no tuvimos que extirpar grandes cantidades de cerebro sano
en el proceso.
Y ahora realmente podemos imaginar un mundo
donde los médicos y cirujanos, extirpan un tumor
sabiendo realmente lo que llevan a cabo,
sin tener que adivinar con su pulgar.
Por eso que es muy importante extirpar esos diminutos tumores sobrantes.
Esos tumores sobrantes, incluso si son solo un puñado de células,
crecerán y replicarán el tumor,
para que el tumor vuelva.
De hecho, la razón por la cual del 80 % a 90 %
de esas neurocirugías de cáncer al final fallarán
es debido a esos pequeños márgenes que se dejaron siendo positivo,
esos pequeños tumores sobrantes que quedaron allí.
Así que esto es claramente muy positivo,
pero lo que realmente quiero compartir con Uds. es adónde nos dirigimos.
Y así, en mi laboratorio en Stanford,
mis estudiantes y yo nos preguntamos ¿en qué deberíamos trabajar ahora?
Y creo que el diagnóstico por imágenes se dirige
a la capacidad de buscar en el cuerpo humano
y ver realmente todas y cada una de estas células por separado.
Esto nos permitirá
detectar tumores de forma temprana, antes de que sean 100 millones de células
y realmente podemos hacer algo al respecto.
La capacidad de ver todas y cada una de las células también nos permitirá
hacer preguntas interesantes.
Así, en el laboratorio, ahora estamos llegando a un punto
donde realmente podemos a hacer a estas células cancerosas preguntas reales,
como, por ejemplo, ¿responde Ud. al tratamiento que le estamos dando o no?
Así que si Ud. no responde, sabremos detener el tratamiento de inmediato,
días después del tratamiento, no en tres meses.
Y así también para pacientes como Ehud
que están pasando por medicamentos de quimioterapia desagradables,
para que ellos no sufran
por esos efectos secundarios terribles de los fármacos
cuando los medicamentos, de hecho, ni siquiera les ayudan.
Así que para ser franco,
estamos bastante lejos de ganar la guerra contra el cáncer,
solo para ser realistas.
Pero al menos tengo la esperanza
de que podemos luchar contra esta guerra
con mejores técnicas para el diagnóstico por imágenes
para evitar ir dando palos a ciegas.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)